and finally new rule just because
FoxNews is obsessed with the Biden sex
assault allegations it doesn't mean the
rest of us have to be you may have
noticed that Donald Trump has one move
accuse you of the very thing he's guilty
of puppet no puppet you're the puppet
remember that one okay
well now it's Joe Biden grabs women by
the [ __ ] not that he even needs to say
it the liberal media and liberal party
is doing it for him exactly what
Republicans want for us to go down the
rabbit hole of Joe Biden's sex monster
so now everybody's investigating but
there is no fact-finding here
it's a he-said she-said she-said
something else entirely
yes Biden's accuser Tara Reid has been
contradicted by multiple people most
importantly Tara Reid this last year she
said of Biden I wasn't scared of him
that he was gonna take me in a room or
anything it wasn't that kind of vibe she
suggested she had filed a sex harassment
report now she says she didn't she says
she was fired by Biden's office but in
deleted posts she said she left because
quote I love Russia with all my heart
President Putin scares the power elite
in America because he is a compassionate
caring visionary leader his obvious
reverence for women children and animals
and his ability with sports is
intoxicating to American women what what
the [ __ ] we're letting this person
change the subject from Donald Trump
lethal incompetence to Joe Biden's sex
monster she literally wrote a love
letter to the murderer trying to keep
Biden from the White House yet the New
York Times is calling for the DNC to
establish a truth panel on this truth
panel huh what which part Putin's
reverence for animals or how
intoxicating he is to women and
Democrats are coalescing around
position that this accusation must be
thoroughly vetted for the party to keep
its credibility well you know
credibility certainly is a problem for
the party on this issue mostly because
they woke themselves into a corner when
they adopted believe women as their
slogan when it should always have been
take accusations seriously Kirsten
Gillibrand said it'd be al franken
allegations the women who came forward
felt it was sexual harassment so it was
that was never tenable because believing
everything doesn't make you noble it
makes you gullible and leaves us with a
world where Republicans don't care about
this stuff so it's just a unilateral
weapon that is used only against
Democrats Trump rides the bus with Billy
Bush we throw al franken under it you
know Democrats are the party of choice
we can choose not to completely [ __ ]
ourselves over this I know it's a sex
scandal and in normal times that's what
we do instead of issues but there are
actually some pretty big problems going
on right now I don't know if you noticed
but America has turned into a failed
state that does a worse job keeping its
citizens alive during a pandemic than
Cambodia and to me that's a little more
important than Tara Reid achieving
closure
she says Biden attacked her and he says
he didn't those are their positions how
about this for yours don't know never
will don't care I care in the macro
about women being attacked of course but
on this one I'm with bogey
who said I'm no good at being noble but
it doesn't take much to see that the
problems of three little people don't
amount to a hill of beans in this crazy
world everybody says we need to do
everything we can to defeat Trump yeah
except anything
well I'm no good at being noble either
but if in 1993 Joe Biden had grabbed my
nuts in a corridor
I was in Washington that year and I had
this knowledge and revealing it could
hurt the guy running against Trump I'd
save it for my memoirs I'd like to think
that I'd have a little more perspective
we have a president who says drink
bleach geez you waited 27 years it
couldn't hold another few months that's
what I would like to ask miss Reid why
now I'm not saying why not 27 years ago
I understand it can take victims years
to come forward I'm saying why not
before Super Tuesday
why not last fall when we still had a
dozen other candidates to choose from
why wait until Biden is our only hope
against Trump and then take him down
this story is gathering and importance
it should not have there is so much at
stake in this next election the entire
world needs to be put back together like
Humpty Dumpty why should one person's
victimhood Trump everyone else's
you